okay [ __ ] okay batches we're gonna be
playing a found freak I don't know what
the [ __ ] it is this is Jesus [ __ ] my
white [ __ ]
Oh Oh mommy mommy back up shut da just
kidding just kidding
Hey okay Wow
this car is amazing okay that's the
blood and it's my blood actually okay
baby shot is that
okay okay here we go here we go oh
that's tense you should be more careful
I saw you coming two blocks ago traffic
cameras they're everywhere in this town
good to know
I'm serious you should toss out your
fancy overpriced phone I can find you
through that - yeah weird having a
conversation like this totally agreed we
should be using like that Navajo code
dialect come up for air I took care of
the daggers sure but down your Gardens
make it look like you're selling secrets
to Assad and moonlighting as a
dominatrix you've created a big enough
disruption for you to move on Matt
Miller but if you want the deck respond
like really gone there's a lot of work
to do all right
I'll hit you up if I need any more help
I threw out your phone chase ass okay
it's do a real one
Cantus going on me and i pick my nose
hard again real slow
I want to broadcast your subconscious
into the deck or user net able to
interact with the avatars of users and
corrupt the abstract representations of
data that are the cornerstone of their
online operation to do that I need an
emo chair of course
Nimmo neurological electromagnetic or
narrow scope a CAD you be destroyed the
only one that has to be smart oh [ __ ]
guys have one impossible how could they
miss the signal they're keeping it here
clover okay nerd time is over what is
this thing and Kinzie for [ __ ] sake
keep it simple I need the chair to stop
the deckers thank you okay good good
let's do this that [ __ ] happened to my
ride
this cars [ __ ] slow is horseshit once
we get to the nuclear plant I'll need to
cut the external power up links to the
main building yeah that can't get done
eggplant yes yes anything comfy while
hooked up to this thing
how should I know it's a chair yeah but
my ass needs some padding that's what
you're worried about
your ass is gonna be comfy a girl
deserves to be pampered sometimes the
ones that gray I think for this chick is
pretty good Jesus
music no thanks no upbeat pop songs to
brighten the mood you're not interested
happy music do you god no classical hard
rock our crew gangsta rap okay you're
lying
what
yeah I don't know insecure Oh [ __ ] ass
dick lights yeah you're like or
everything way too hard or something and
the head is like bleeding for an hour
over here already Jesus
all right here's the powerup link
locations keep the Decker's often as I
like save each one yeah that's who the
Faro first
I guess it was [ __ ] runnin all over
right this looks like it finally the
time to shut down this power no problem
oh [ __ ] that guy hear me
okay
cheesy mind keeping it down out there
you can't be serious Kenzi sorta man
this shit's like [ __ ] rocket can
together baby that's one two okay okay
let's do this let's do this
okay okay that is okay here they are
okay
[ __ ] it there that's I he's never on the
roof usually how [ __ ] my [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] like I saw something over
here now okay I guess not
hurry up Kenzie look at that booty look
at my butt yeah yeah it's better you
cool Kinzie these things take time
I can do it go ahead and touch it last
one in we're in business
okay come on okay good
get again God God got a gun get get get
I think when they get in the car and you
strive ask them five five five five
man let's take those ladies along let's
go [ __ ] all right now can we get that
amazing padded chair nope
now we go up in a helicopter you never
told me about the helicopter I have to
triangulate its exact location first of
all you act as the guardian see we're
communicating where's it landed okay
this is faster
[ __ ] where the [ __ ] are we on it's just
a wait who the [ __ ] is that [ __ ]
all right we have to fly around the area
for this tour okay we'll do your thing
and I'll take over from there don't go
schoolteacher on me break
Oh
so basically I press the off button shut
okay I guess I'm just so I can jump in
that [ __ ] I'm so much faster for a jump
let me get hurt I know there's [ __ ]
in here
there's always [ __ ]
[ __ ] I get up there chef
Oh
now [ __ ] [ __ ] slow
kick ass come on come on turn off that
router [ __ ]
honey [ __ ] backup okay I'm glad I
have their number
[ __ ] that was [ __ ] hardboard I got my
tits hard don't my tits hard violins
always get my tits hard
hey there's a guy behind me it says Oh
who are the people that are okay I got
ahead ideas I carry here this is a [ __ ]
over here
I see he's in it
it's out for Harambee